well now to the new season of dancing
with the stars and our dancing insider
cameron have been right here with me now
no real surprises here no not really we
kind of knew who it was going to be but
it doesn't make it any less exciting
though does it season 25 here we go now
it promises to bring some real
competitive heat starting with one major
ballroom wife swap
the shade ski
i like it it's tv gold
for the first time in dancing history
married couples are switching up on the
dance floor nick and vanessa lachey are
partnering up with pros max murkowski
and peter murgatroyd and make no mistake
they are all in it to win it i've caught
myself in the bathroom like brushing my
teeth or holding the baby and i'm like
and then nick is in the is it on the
other new yorkers
i mean obviously you don't want to bring
too much of it home and we tend to be
competitive but i think at the same time
it's cool to have the kind of support
system
[Music]
well real quick who's ever really taken
a dance lesson anybody this morning's
live announcement on gma didn't hold any
casting surprises but here's our
breakdown into the dancing dynamics for
the season we see a lot of chemistry
between property brothers twin drew
scott and pro emma slater this is a new
spin-off from dancing with the stars by
property brothers this is the drew nema
show
another twin to watch pro wrestler nikki
bella teaming up with artem chief
instead her strategy wrestling moves
there's a few like head scissors take
down and a few steps i think we can
incorporate into dance moves a total of
four pro athletes will be vying for the
mirror ball trophy this season as well
as four musicians including debbie
gibson i want to do the show now because
over the last four years i've been
dealing with health challenges in
particular lyme disease here's something
else we can tell you don't expect
everyone to bear all everyone on the
show always has their shirt open or off
i'm like i can't do that i don't have
that that was you you couldn't keep your
shirt on yeah but there was there was a
few buttons open uh on a few of my
outfits for sure what do you say we do
some pics right now i'm going derrick
fisher and sharda i'm going to go
terrell owens and cheryl and my last
pick vanessa lachey and max i like it
i'm going nick lachey i love me some
names thank you dancer too and i got to
give a shout out for drew oh yeah
because he's my buddy i don't know if he
can dance but he's my friend i love that
i love that you threw derek fisher in
there d fish is my man he has no shot